Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速告诉大家一个正在进行的激动人心的好消息。如果你曾想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续收入冲刺挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家的人、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide.
这些原则同样适用于你。此外，还有由丽莎本人亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特（Dr. Marianne Trent）博士进行一对一教练辅导的小时名额。想了解更多吗？你当然想。快去我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情告诉你。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正期待成为一名心理学家，那么就让这期节目作为你的指南。
With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. Without a merry entrance it love me but I'm also on camera today. So if you're not listening on YouTube you could come along and see me talk through what we're going to be talking to you about today but there is no pressure. So if you are in the UK at the moment you will have noticed there's lots of stuff in the media still about grief and you know people talking about a grief hangover and that's something that people have been telling me about kind of personally and professionally you know the effect of the media and the kind of more dour presentation and the songs and the music and the the kind of reflective things that we've been subjected to really as part of living in the UK. And, you know,
有了这个播客一路相伴，你将稳步迈向获得专业资格的道路。这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持的《有志心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）。没有开场白它就喜欢我，但我今天也出镜了。所以，如果你不是在 YouTube 上收听，你可以来观看我讲述我们今天要讨论的内容，不过这没有任何压力。所以，如果你目前身在英国，你会发现媒体上仍然有很多关于悲悼的内容，你知道，人们谈论着悲伤的“宿醉效应”，这是人们在个人和职业层面上一直在向我倾诉的事情，你知道，媒体的影响、那种更加凝重的呈现方式、歌曲、音乐，以及作为在英国生活的一部分，我们真正经历的那些反思性的事物。而且，你知道，
that can feel tricky because what we know is that it doesn't always feel safe to be sad. But for me, you know, I very much try to live by my values and my values as a psychologist and I think that you know being able to tap into all of our range of emotions including sadness which is key is very important to me both personally and professionally and so you know I'm always intrigued to know what your values are. Today, we're going to be doing a values exercise for me, based on me, using some acceptance and commitment therapy values cards. So why don't you, you know, see how you get on with this exercise. In fact, if you'd like to come on and do an aspiring psychologist set of values episode, let me know and I'll have you on as a guest. Let me know if you'd be up for that. So what we're going to do is we're firstly going to pick the goal I want to work on. And then I'm going to identify my core core values out of a big set of values. So let's get on with that. So picking from the life domains,
这可能会让人觉得很棘手，因为我们知道，感到悲伤并不总是让人觉得是安全的。但对我来说，你知道，我极力试图按照自己的价值观生活，以及我作为一名心理学家的价值观，我认为，你知道，能够触及我们所有的情绪，包括悲伤——这是关键所在——无论在个人还是职业层面上，对我来说都非常重要。所以，你知道，我总是很好奇你的价值观是什么。今天，我们将根据我本人，使用一些接纳承诺疗法（ACT）的价值观卡片，来为一个价值观练习。所以，为什么不（你知道的）看看你在这个练习中表现如何呢？事实上，如果你想上节目来做一个“有志心理学家价值观”的主题，请告诉我，我会邀请你作为嘉宾上节目。让我知道你是否有兴趣。所以我们要做的，首先是挑选我想要努力实现的目标。然后，我要从一大堆价值观中找出我的核心核心价值观。让我们开始吧。所以从生活的各个领域中挑选，
can I show you that so that you can see it on camera? We've got family, parenting, intimate partner, friends and social life, work and career, health, education and learning environment community spirituality personal growth and leisure and I am going to because we're talking about psychology I'm going to talk about work and career in this so there's a massive massive stack of values to work through. And what I've done is I've picked a section of them, a selection of them, and I've whittled down the ones that are most important to me. So in no particular order, we have cooperation. So to be cooperative and collaborative with others. We have contribution.
我能把它展示给你们看以便你们能在镜头前看到它吗？我们有家庭、育儿、亲密伴侣、朋友与社交生活、工作与职业、健康、教育与学习环境、社区、灵活性与个人成长以及休闲。因为我们在谈论心理学，所以我要在这个环节谈论工作和/或职业。这里有一大堆需要筛选的价值观。我所做的是挑选了其中的一部分，精选出对我有最重要的那些。所以排名不分先后，我们有：合作。即与他人合作和协作。我们有：贡献。
To contribute, give, help, assist, share or be generous. Creativity. To be creative or innovative at work or at play. We have trust, to be trustworthy, loyal, faithful, sincere and reliable and or be trusting of others. We have friendliness, to be warm, friendly, open, accepting, agreeable and helpful towards others. We have industry, to be industrious, hardworking, committed, proactive or dedicated. We have honesty, to be honest, truthful and sincere with myself and others. Safety, to secure, protect or ensure my own safety or that of others.
去贡献、给予、帮助、协助、分享或慷慨大方。创造力。在工作或娱乐中具有创造力或创新精神。我们有：信任。要值得信任、忠诚、忠实、真诚和可靠，并且/或者信任他人。我们有：友善。对他人热情、友好、开放、接纳、随和且乐于助人。我们有：勤奋。要勤奋、努力、投入、积极主动或专心致志。我们有：诚实。对自己和他人诚实、真实和真诚。安全。保障、保护或确保我自身或他人的安全。
Compassion. To act kindly towards myself and or others when in pain. Courage. To be courageous or brave. To persist in the face of fear, uncertainty and threatening circumstances. Connection, to engage fully in whatever I'm doing, to give the activity or the person I'm with my full attention. And last but not least, curiosity, to be curious, open-minded and interested, eager to explore, discover and learn and out of those I picked some top ones so I whittled it down to curiosity connection courage compassion and friendliness but that is too many so oh and trust um that's too many so I'm going to go for compassion connection I'm going to fall
同情。在痛苦时对自我和/或他人表现出仁慈。勇气。要有勇气或勇敢。在面对恐惧、不确定性和威胁时坚持不懈。连接。全心投入我正在做的任何事情，将我的全部注意力倾注在活动或同伴身上。最后但同样重要的是，好奇心。要好奇、开明、感兴趣，渴望探索、发现和学习。在这些当中，我选出了一些排名前列的，我把它们精选为：好奇心、连接、勇气、同情和友善。但这太多了，哦还有信任……这太多了，所以我要选择同情、连接、我将（技术上来说）
technically only supposed to have three, curiosity and courage. And the rest of them I'm going to say, thank you, you're very important to me, but my core values as a professional are those of curiosity, courage, connection and compassion. Now already I'm thinking, oh no, I'm missing, I miss those other bits, but I think these are, you know, my core values, I think. Okay, so the next part of this activity is living your values. So when I'm living by these values of compassion, connection, courage and curiosity, how do I treat myself? How do I treat others? How do I treat myself how do I treat others how do I treat my body how do I treat my work and education how do I treat my interests or hobbies and how do I treat the world around me okay so
其实只应该选三个：好奇心、勇气。至于其余的，我要说：谢谢你们，你们对我非常重要，但作为一名专业人士，我的核心价值观是好奇心、勇气、连接和同情。现在我已经在想了：“哦不，我漏掉了，我漏掉了其他部分，”但我想这些就是（你知道的）我的核心价值观，我想是的。好的，那么这个活动的下一部分是：活出你的价值观。所以，当我秉持着同情、连接、勇气和好奇心的价值观生活时，我如何对待自己？我如何对待他人？我如何对待自己、我如何对待他人、我如何对待我的身体、我如何对待我的工作和教育、我如何对待我的兴趣或爱好，以及我如何对待我周围的世界？好吧，
when I treat myself I very much practice being compassionate these days. And that was something that I didn't really have along my journey to being an aspiring psychologist. And so very much in the upcoming Aspiring Psychologist book, I encourage you and the other people within that book, encourage you to be self-compassionate. And I think that is absolutely key and we have a foreword by Dr Chris Irons in the book as well who is you know one of the very leading voices in in self-compassion and compassion focused therapy right now so so we're privileged to have him in the book um i'm very
当我对待自己时，如今我非常践行自我同情。而在我成为有志心理学家的历程中，我并没有真正具备这种能力。因此，在即将出版的《有志心理学家》一书中，我极力鼓励你以及书中的其他人，鼓励你们对自己充满同情。我认为这绝对是关键所在。我们在书中还有克里斯·艾恩斯博士（Dr Chris Irons）写的序言，他目前是自我同情和聚焦同情疗法领域最权威的声音之一，所以我们有幸能邀请他为本书作序。嗯，我非常
grateful for him saying yes and i guess that's one of my values as well as courage you know i asked him if he would do it and he said yes you know and i guess i have similar courage with my clients so i have the courage to have difficult conversations I have the curiosity to explore that in a way that doesn't feel intrusive, you know, a way that still feels respectful. So we have that connection, you know. I have this almost palpable, visceral sense of connection with my clients and with people I work with and that's really really important to me so I treat others with compassion I demonstrate my courage to myself and to them and I'm curious about myself as well I'm quite reflective generally so I speak to you today whilst I've been to a funeral.
感谢他答应了我的请求。我想这也是我的价值观之一——勇气。你知道，我问他是否愿意写序，他答应了。我想我对我的来访者也有着类似的勇气：我有勇气展开艰难的对话，我有好奇心去以一种不让人觉得具有侵入性的方式去探索——你知道的，一种仍然让人感到尊重的方去探索。所以我们有了那种连接，你知道的。我和我的来访者、和我共事的人之间有一种几乎触手可得的、发自内心的连接感，这对我来说真的非常非常重要。所以我以同情对待他人，向自己和他们展现我的勇气，我也对自我保持好奇。我通常会进行很多反思。今天我来跟你录音时，刚去参加了一场葬礼。
Part of the grief continues. I'm hoping that's going to be it for us for now, for the next foreseeable. But, you know, I'm always curious about that. I'm curious to hear about others' lives and to learn about other people. I was just doing a live just before I started this podcast and I saw that my postman was back after a very long period of what I was assuming was sickness absence. But I actually went and stopped. Well, he rang the doorbell and my husband was out. But I went to go and answer the door and I stopped the live and then came back to it. I was curious about him because I have a connection with him and I felt compassionate to him. And I'm, you know, courageous as well.
悲伤的一部分还在继续。我希望在可预见的未来里，对我们来说这就够了。但是，你知道的，我总是对此感到好奇。我很好奇去了解别人的生活，去了解其他人。就在我开始录制这个播客之前，我刚刚做了一场直播，我看到我的邮递员在经历了很长一段时间（我猜是病假）之后回来了。但我其实停了下来——好吧，他按了门铃，我丈夫出去了。但我去开门，暂停了直播，然后又回来看直播。我对他的情况很好奇，因为我和他有一种连接感，我对他也怀有同情心。而且，你知道的，我也很有勇气。
So I was like, oh, you know, how are you? How have you been? And, you know, he tells me a story. And I ended up singing him the song that my children had made up about him um about where he might be it was basically his name which I won't tell you because it's not not appropriate for me to do that um you know and ends in all the verses are different country names where he might be um they're trying to make sense of where the postman had gone and he he very much enjoyed that and he said said he was going to try and add a few more verses before he next saw me about the countries that he could have been in, but wasn't. So yeah, I just try to be curious with everybody really. And I'm curious at work,
所以我当时就说：“哦，你知道的，你好吗？你最近怎么样？”然后，你知道的，他给我讲了一个故事。我最后甚至还给他唱了我孩子们为他编的一首歌，关于他可能去了哪里。那基本上是他的名字（我不会告诉你，因为这样做不合适），你知道的，所有的诗句结尾都是不同的国家名字，代表他可能去过的地方。他们试图弄明白邮递员去了哪里。他非常喜欢这个，他说下次再见到我之前，他要试着再多编几段关于他可能去过但实际上没有去的国家的歌词。所以，是的，我真的只是努力对每个人都保持好奇心。我在工作中也保持好奇，
treating my interests or hobbies. I don't feel like I've got many at the moment it's mainly writing books and that's kind of taking a lot of time um but I'm going to the theater um tomorrow um and I'm also going the next week which is entirely accidental um scheduling um and you know I guess am I going to be curious about that I'm kind of curious because I'm going to be seeing something I don't really remember wanting to see and yet apparently I did agree to go and see it and that's Mamma Mia I'm not hugely looking forward to it it's also my wedding anniversary that it's on and so I didn't even know I was I didn't remember I was going because I would have thought originally I said no to going out on my wedding anniversary day. So I'm curious about that. How's that going
对待我的兴趣或爱好。我觉得我目前好像没有多少爱好，主要是写书，这占用了我大量的时间。不过我明天要去看戏剧，下周还要去看戏剧——这完全是偶然的排期。而且，你知道的，我在想我会对这个感兴趣吗？我其实挺好奇的，因为我要看一部我根本记不起自己想看的剧，但显然我确实同意去看它，那就是《妈妈咪呀》（Mamma Mia）。我其实并不是非常期待，而且那天正好是我的结婚纪念日。所以甚至连自己要去看我都记不清了，因为我本来以为自己一开始会拒绝在结婚纪念日那天出门的。所以对此我很好奇，那会是怎样的一场体验
to be? I think sometimes as my sister-in-law just said to me, if you've got low expectations, then you're easily pleased. And I think that's going to be the case for this musical I'm going to. So that's living by my values. So how would I set goals in the next 24 hours, in the next week, in the next two weeks, month, year and decade? Decade's a big one, isn't it? So I would want to continue to be connected with others. So even though I do lots of passive stuff, I will always do one-to-one client work because it's really important to me to have that sense of connection and to be able to help demonstrate my skills in compassion, curiosity and courage. So in the next decade, I would hope to still be
呢？我想有时候正如我嫂子刚刚对我说的那样：“如果你期望很低，那么你很容易就会感到满意。”我想我去看这部音乐剧时也会是这样。这就是活出我的价值观。那么，在接下来的24小时、接下来的一周、接下来的两周、一个月、一年和十年里，我会如何设定目标呢？十年是一个很大的跨度，对吧？所以我希望继续与他人保持连接。因此，即使我做了很多被动的事情，我也永远会做一对一的来访者工作，因为对我来说，拥有那种连接感，以及能够展现我在同情、好奇和勇气方面的技能，真的是非常重要的。所以在接下来的十年里，我希望自己依然能够
seeing clients and in holding on to those values that will very much keep me grounded and keep me focused. And I really liked that when I was working in the NHS, some of the people in more senior management had still kept a very small caseload because I guess that sense of connection and sense of doing something in industry was really important to them to be doing their core profession and I absolutely think that I would have been the same as well so I probably would have been um if I if I progressed and progressed I'd have been the chief exec that still had you know a clinic and saw three clients a week because it was really important to me to do that um so yeah I think I'm very much I've got an idea of where my my work is going. Perhaps we'd like to do some more training in compassion focused therapy and to continue with my supervisory relationships as well for connection and curiosity.
接诊来访者，并且坚守这些价值观，这会让双脚紧踩大地、保持专注。我真的很喜欢这一点：当我在NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）工作时，一些更高层管理人员仍然保留着非常少量的个案工作量，因为我猜这种连接感和在行业中做实事的成就感对他们来说非常重要，能够让他们坚守核心专业。我完全相信，如果换作我也会是一样的。所以如果我不断晋升、晋升，我大概会成为那种依然拥有一个诊所、每周看三个来访者的首席执行官，因为做这件事对我来说真的非常重要。所以，是的，我想我真的很清楚我的工作方向在哪里。也许我们想在聚焦同情疗法（CFT）方面接受更多的培训，并继续保持我的督导关系，以获得连接和好奇心。
So I'm going to whip through these because we haven't got a super amount of time. So I'm not going to do action planning, which is where we look at the actions we take to achieve the goals. We're going to look at encouraging values, and we're going to look at that after this short break, which I hope you enjoy. Enjoy the jingle, won't you? that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. clinical psychologist collective book is the book to read for aspiring psychologists
所以我要快点把这些讲完，因为我们的时间真的不多。所以我不打算做行动规划——也就是我们寻找实现目标的具体行动的环节。我们要探讨的是：如何鼓励价值观。我们将在短暂的休息之后探讨这个，希望你们会喜欢。好好享受这段音乐铃声吧，好吗？它将助你获得专业资格。快来看看吧。它就在这本书里。这就是《临床心理学家集锦》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。这就是《临床心理学家集锦》。《临床心理学家集锦》这本书是立志成为心理学家的人必读的书籍。
like most aspiring psychologists i've read all the books about becoming a clinical psychologist. While other books break down the entry criteria and speak of the course competitiveness, the Clinical Psychologist Collective reveals the varied journeys and individual differences of those who've gotten onto and completed training. It inspired me to embrace my own journey and make the most of my experiences and identity. If you read one book about becoming a clinical psychologist, this is it. If you buy someone who aspires to be a clinical psychologist a book, this is it. This book will help profession blossom into a more diverse group of mental health practitioners who use their backgrounds to enhance their ability to support those we serve. Let this be your guide Filled with lessons and experience That will help you get qualified
就像大多数有志心理学家一样，我读过所有关于如何成为临床心理学家的书。虽然其他书详细剖析了准入标准并谈论了课程的竞争激烈程度，但《临床心理学家集锦》揭示了那些成功考入并完成培训的人们丰富多彩的历程和各不相同的个性差异。它激励我拥抱自己的旅程，充分利用自己的经历和身份认同。如果你只读一本关于如何成为临床心理学家的书，那就是这本。如果你要送给一个立志成为临床心理学家的人一本书，那就是这本。这本书将帮助这个行业绽放出更加多元化的心理健康从业者群体，他们运用自身的背景来增强自己支持我们所服务对象的能力。让这本书成为你的指南，充满经验与教训，助你获得专业资格。
So come and take a look It's right here in this book It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective It's the clinical psychologist collective welcome back to you let's think um some more about my personal values as a qualified clinical psychologist. And this might well be a really useful exercise that you could do. And like I said, in the first half, if you might be interested in coming on as a guest on the podcast to explore your values as an aspiring psychologist, then do let me know and let's see what we can sort out so
所以快来看看吧，它就在这本书里。这就是《临床心理学家集锦》。这就是《临床心理学家集锦》。欢迎回来，让我们更多地思考一下我作为一名合格临床心理学家的个人价值观。这可能是一个非常实用的练习，你也可以尝试去做。就像我说的，在前半部分，如果你有兴趣作为嘉宾来到播客节目中，探讨你作为一名有志心理学家的价值观，请务必告诉我，让我们看看能如何安排。
if you didn't catch the first half my values i've identified are compassion connection courage and curiosity um so those are the ones that i have picked out from a large selection of values. So how will I encourage those values? And who else would I like to encourage these values in? Well, I'd very much like to encourage the values of compassion and courage and curiosity within my children. I think that's really important you know uh i blubbed a river full of tears um when i went to my eldest child's first um merit assembly which i think was in reception year so he would have been four um and he was given his merit and within the merit award they mentioned his kindness you know a number of times and then teachers came up to me afterwards to tell me what a kind little
如果你错过了前半部分，我确立的价值观是：同情、连接、勇气和好奇心。这些是我从大量的价值观中挑选出来的。那么，我将如何鼓励这些价值观？我又希望在谁身上鼓励这些价值观呢？嗯，我非常希望在我的孩子们身上鼓励同情、勇气和好奇心的价值观。我认为这真的很重要。你知道的，我去大孩子参加的第一个荣誉颁奖大会时，哭得泪流成河。我想那是在学前班（Reception Year），当时他大概四岁。他获得了荣誉奖，而在颁奖词中，老师好几次提到了他的善良。后来老师们还走过来告诉我，他是一个多么善良的小男孩，他对班上的同伴以及对老师们都多么体贴。
boy he was and how thoughtful he was to his to his peers in the class and to the staff as well and you know that just really moved me actually you know it's really really wonderful I really really think that kindness is the most wonderful thing but kindness isn't the same as letting people walk all over you you know it isn't it's just that you know how nice it is to be connected with other people and we can show people kindness without being a doormat absolutely um and he's certainly nobody's doormat now that he's nine um but he's still you know very much reported as being a really nice member of the class that gets along with people and is you know a pleasure to teach um let's see what they say about his little brother he's a little bit more of a handful
你知道，这真的深深触动了我。这真的、真的是一件非常美妙的事情。我真的、真的认为善良是最美好的事情。但善良并不等于任由别人践踏你，它绝对不是。只是你明白与他人建立连接是多么美好的一件事，我们可以在不当受气包的前提下向人们展现善良。绝对是的。而且他现在九岁了，绝对不是任何人的受气包，但据报道，他依然是一个非常讨人喜欢的班级成员，能和大家相处融洽，而且老师觉得教他是一种享受。让我们看看他们对他的弟弟怎么说——弟弟稍微有点让人头疼。
um but how can i model these values well it's really tricky actually um as a mummy um you know sometimes i i try always to be compassionate but i'm not always super patient you know and maybe that's something for me to reflect upon you know how can I increase my patience to my pre-grief levels so before 2017 I feel like I was more easygoing I had more patience generally but also the children are older now and are less compliant you know when I ask my eldest to go and brush his teeth now I get one sec one sec and then I prompt again a couple of minutes later because we're trying to hustle out the door and I still get one sec and it's like mummy can ask you kind of calmly and quite nicely about three times but after that I'm not going to be quite so calm you know so I absolutely used to be really into gentle parenting but I just found it wasn't really
嗯，但我该如何为这些价值观树立榜样呢？这其实真的很棘手。作为一位母亲，你知道的，有时我虽然总是努力保持同情，但我并不总是超级有耐心。也许这也是我需要反思的一点：我该如何将我的耐心提升到“前悲伤时期”的水平呢？所以在2017年之前，我觉得我更加随和，总体上更有耐心。但同时，孩子们现在长大了，也不那么听话了。你知道，当我让大儿子去刷牙时，我得到的回答是：“等一下，等一下。”然后几分钟后我再次催促，因为我们正赶着出门，结果得到的还是“等一下”。这就好像妈妈可以很冷静、很友善地问你大约三次，但在此之后，我就不会那么冷静了。所以，你知道的，我以前绝对非常热衷于温和育儿（Gentle Parenting），但我只是发现它其实并不……
I still would I guess get on board with the philosophies of gentle parenting but it's all very I found it very easy when I just had one child. And it got trickier when I had two children. And as they both start to grow and want different things, I just found it a bit trickier. So on a great day, I'd still say I'm a gentle parent. I would tend to hope to say that I was compassionate and connected most of the time. But when my youngest is trying to climb me whilst I'm trying to make breakfast literally he climbs me like I'm like a tree and he's a monkey um shins up me in all sorts you know cute to begin with but when you're trying
我想我还是会认同温和育儿的理念，但我发现，当我只有一个孩子时，这一切非常简单。而当我有了两个孩子时，事情就变得棘手了。随着他们两个都开始长大，想要不同的东西，我发现这变得有点棘手了。所以在状态好的一天里，我仍然会说我是一个温和育儿的母亲。我倾向于认为自己在绝大多数时候都是富有同情心且充满连接的。但当我的小儿子试图在我做早餐时往我身上爬——字面意思，他把我当成一棵树，而他是一只猴子，顺着我各种往上爬。一开始觉得挺可爱的，但当你要
to butter toast and stuff it's a bit annoying you know get down you know we'll do this later it's nice that you want to climb me. It's nice that you love me. He's trying to climb up to kiss me as well. He's very cute, very cute. But, yeah, I think I would like to think that I don't want the children to think I'm not connected to them or not compassionate towards them because I've got other things to do and i'm
抹面包黄油之类的时候，这其实有点烦人。“下来，我们待会儿再做这事。你想爬我这很好，你爱我也很好。”他甚至还想爬上来亲吻我。他非常可爱，真的很可爱。但是，是的，我想我认为我不希望孩子们觉得我没有和他们连接，或者对他们缺乏同情，仅仅因为我有其他事情要做，而且我没有以前那么有耐心了。
not as patient as i used to be um and i think maybe curiosity is something i could do with a bit more for the kids you know so they often all time tell me things i don't know about roblox or about football and it's not my specialist subject it's not something I'm super super interested in but that's certainly something I perhaps now I've identified my values will try to gently increase you know try to broaden that dialogue a little bit more um how can i initiate or teach or instruct these values well i think i do that really well in my one-to-one work um absolutely modeling that compassion and the connection and exploring the fact that it's safe you know to try courageous things in
我想也许好奇心是我对孩子们可以再多一点的地方。你知道的，他们经常告诉我一些我不知道的事情，关于《Roblox》（罗布乐思）或者关于足球，这不是我的专业领域，也不是我超级感兴趣的事情。但这绝对是我现在既然已经识别了自己的价值观后，会尝试轻轻增加的一点——你知道的，试着稍微拓宽一点那种对话。嗯，我该如何发起、教导或指导这些价值观呢？我想我在自己的一对一工作中做得非常好，绝对是在模范展现同情和连接，并去探索在我们的会谈中尝试那些
our sessions that you may not have done before and to be curious and see whether we can take that outside of the therapeutic space to try that and I absolutely encourage these values in you as aspiring psychologists as well and that's absolutely the case within the aspiring psychologist membership and the clinical psychologisthip and the Clinical Psychologist Collective and the Aspiring Psychologist Collective, which is coming out very soon. You'll be pleased to know we should be on track for the 3rd of October. So yeah, exciting times. There is much to do still, lots of editing to be done, but hopefully by the time you are listening to this podcast episode the majority of it will be finished so yes I may be laying flat in a dark room exhausted um but even then
你以前可能没有做过的勇敢事情是安全的，并且保持好奇，看看我们是否能将这种尝试带到治疗空间之外去实践。我绝对也鼓励你们作为有志心理学家拥有这些价值观，这在“有志心理学家会员社群”（Aspiring Psychologist Membership）、“临床心理学家会员社群”（Clinical Psychologisthip）以及即将推出的《临床心理学家集锦》和《有志心理学家集锦》中绝对是这样的。你会高兴地知道，我们应该在10月3日按计划出版。所以，是的，激动人心的时刻。还有很多事情要做，有很多编辑工作要完成，但希望当你听到这一期播客时，大部分工作都已经完成了。所以，是的，我可能正瘫在一个黑暗的房间里筋疲力尽，但即便如此，
I am you know being courageous in putting this book out there um being curious what you guys will think to it um connected because this is stuff you want you know stuff that you're interested in you've told me um you know this is something you want to read um so i'm listening to my audience and i'm being compassionate because it's absolutely very tricky to be um the provider of mental health services in a mental health emergency which it feels like we're currently in in the UK as a result of many factors but including the pandemic and the effects of that. So yeah I try to make sure that I am initiating and teaching those well. How can I create situations or environments or relationships where these values thrive so I
我也（你知道的）勇敢地把这本书推向世界，对你们会如何看待它感到好奇，并感到连接，因为这是你们想要的东西，是你们感兴趣的东西，你们告诉过我，（你知道的）这是你们想要阅读的内容。所以我倾听我的听众，我怀有同情心，因为作为英国目前似乎正处于心理健康紧急状态中的心理健康服务提供者，要做到这一点真的非常棘手——这种紧急状态是由多种因素造成的，包括大流行及其带来的影响。所以，是的，我努力确保自己能够很好地发起和教导这些价值观。我该如何创造这些价值观能够蓬勃发展的局势、环境或关系呢？我想
guess yeah I can continue to offer sessions to new clients I can continue to offer supervision coaching sessions and one-to-one therapy did I say that already I think I did and I can continue to help my members in the membership to be really curious to be really courageous to connect with myself with others and with the clients they're working for in a compassionate way. How can we reward these values when you see them in others? So absolutely, when I see people reaching out to their network and being connected, that's something really to celebrate. When I see they're doing things courageously, like being sad when they don't usually feel like it's safe to be sad, that takes real courage, but also compassion. We're absolutely checking into and tapping into sadness as being a really important part of human emotion and knowing that's
是的，我可以继续为新来访者提供个案会谈，我可以继续提供督导、教练会谈和一对一体疗——我是不是刚刚已经说过这个了？我想是的。我可以继续帮助会员社群里的成员真正保持好奇、真正勇敢、以富有同情心地与我本人、与他人以及与他们所服务的来访者建立连接。当我们看到别人身上展现出这些价值观时，我们该如何给予奖励呢？毫无疑问，当我看到人们向他们的人际网络伸出援手并建立连接时，那是绝对值得庆祝的事情。当我看到他们勇敢地做事时——比如在通常觉得不安全的时候允许自己悲伤，这需要真正的勇气，但也需要同情。我们绝对是在审视并挖掘悲伤，将其视为人类情绪中非常重要的一部分，并知道这样做对我们来说是
safe for us to do. Okay, so the final one we're going to do in this exercise is twisting values. And that's the idea that our minds can easily twist our values into rigid or unhelpful rules. So can we notice any of these classic twists? I should do this, I have to do that, I must do the other, this is the right thing to do, that is the wrong thing to do, if I don't do this I'm bad and if I manage to do that I good. Remember, there are no good or bad, right or wrong, should or must in a value. And I think that's, yeah, for make sure that I am not over cramming my diary there's only certain um certain slots I have in my diary each week for one-to-one and once they're full they're full and I've always worked that way since um since being in my first qualified role as well which was a choice and partnership approach so a kappa service and so there was job plans so
安全的。好的，我们在这次练习中要做的最后一点是：扭曲价值观。这个观点是，我们的思维很容易将我们的价值观扭曲成僵硬的或无益的规则。那么，我们能注意到任何这些经典的扭曲形式吗？“我应该这样做”、“我不得不那样做”、“我必须做另一件事”、“这是正确的事情”、“那是错误的事情”、“如果我不这样做，我就是坏的；如果我设法做到了，那我就好了”。记住，在价值观中没有好坏、对错、应该或必须。我认为这，是的，为了确保我不会把我的日程表塞得太满，我在日程表里每周只为一对一体疗留出特定数量的名额，一旦满了就满了。自从我担任第一个合格职位以来，我一直都是这样工作的，
everything was very predictable and that really set me up well for being boundaried with my time and being compassionate to myself and being clear about what was coming and what was next and so I really really like that way of working and that's the way that I continue to do that and I might well record a podcast episode on job planning and how's the way that I continue to do that and I might well record a podcast episode on job planning and how I use that because I absolutely still do that now but I you know also sometimes the compassionate thing to do is to say no to things so if you get invited to things and you don't want to do them um case in point you know there must have been a good reason why I said yes to the musical um maybe that's still to become clear um you know
那是一个选择与合作的模式（Choice and Partnership Approach），所以是一个卡帕服务（CAPA service），因此有工作计划（Job Plans），所以一切都非常可预测。这真的为我打下了很好的基础，让我能够为自己的时间设立边界，对自己保持同情，并对接下来要发生什么、什么在后面保持清晰。所以我非常非常喜欢这种工作方式，这也是我一直延续至今的工作方式。我可能还会录制一期关于“工作计划”的播客节目，讲讲我是如何使用它的，因为我直到现在也绝对还在这样做。但我也（你知道的）有时候富有同情心的做法是对事情说“不”。所以如果你受邀参加某些活动而你又不想去的话——
also I went to see Les Miserables with my sister-in-law recently and we'd originally booked it in 20 it might have been in 2018 and it was supposed to be taking ahead taking place in 2020 um and of course it got cancelled and postponed and postponed and postponed. But I didn't even like the film when I watched it. It's just that she really, really loved the musical and really wanted to see it and nobody else fancied it with her.
举个例子，你知道的，我同意去看那部音乐剧背后肯定有一个很好的理由，也许这还有待日后明朗。你知道，最近我和我嫂子去看《悲惨世界》（Les Misérables），我们最初是在20年（可能是2018年）预定的，本应在2020年上演，当然，它被取消了，然后一推再推、一推再推、一推再推。但我看电影时甚至都不喜欢它。只是她真的、真的非常喜欢这部音乐剧，非常想看，而且没有其他人愿意陪她去。
So it was really expensive, but because it was important to her and I didn't want her not to be able to see it, I agreed to go. And we, you know, we had a lovely time and in the end we went for dinner as well beforehand. We a really nice evening so I'm really pleased we did that and it was I was pleasantly surprised I really enjoyed it it was really really great performance so sometimes we can so long as it's not harmful to us we can do things that we're not super thrilled
所以票真的很贵，但因为这对她很重要，而我不想让她错过看剧的机会，我答应去了。我们（你知道的）度过了一段美好的时光，最后我们在演出前还去吃了个晚餐。我们度过了一个非常美好的夜晚，所以我真的很高兴我这么做了，而且我感到惊喜，我真的很喜欢它，这是一场非常非常棒的演出。所以有时候，只要对我们没有害处，我们可以去做那些并不是超级狂热的事情，它也可能会给我们带来极好的结果。当然，这对于连接来说也很重要。你知道的，我尊重我的嫂子，我爱她——如果你在听的话（虽然你不会听，因为你不是心理学家，但也许我会让你听这一期）。你知道的，我们可以建立连接，我们可以尊重他人。你知道的，我可以拿出勇气去看那些我认为自己不会喜欢的演出。我公公非常喜欢《妈妈咪呀》。
with and it might lead to a great outcome for us too and of course that's important with connection you know so I respect my sister-in-law I love her if you're listening which you're not because you're not a psychologist but maybe I'll make you listen to this one um you know we can be connected and we can respect others um you know and I can I can be courageous into going to things see things I don't think I'm going to enjoy. My father-in-law really loves Mamma Mia. And so maybe part of my reason for being courageous was to see him really enjoying himself. So that might well be part of my reason for saying yes to something that I wasn't actually that thrilled for. Now I think about it um so yeah I'm I guess with compassion being one of the values there's less
所以也许我表现出勇气的理由之一，就是看到他玩得那么开心。这很可能就是我答应一件其实我并没有那么兴奋的事情的部分原因。现在我想想看——所以，是的，我想随着同情成为核心价值观之一，
likely to be the shoulds and the have-tos and the rights and the wrongs and I'm bad if I don't and I'm should and I must and I you know if I don't then I'm an awful human um but also with that natural reflex reflexivity and reflection that we get with curiosity, I try not to be too harsh on myself. One of my friends has got about three or four full-time jobs, and I'm always trying to encourage her to, you know, maybe to do a little less, which is ironic for a lady who does as much as I do as well. But how have you found that?
“应该”、“必须”、“正确”、“错误”、“如果我不做我就是个糟糕的人”、“我应该”、“我必须”、“如果我不这样做我就是个可怕的人”这种情况就会减少。但同时，伴随着好奇心带来的那种自然的反思能力和反省，我努力不对自己太苛刻。我的一个朋友有三到四份全职工作，我总是试图鼓励她（你知道的）稍微少做一点，这对于一个像我一样做了这么多事情的女性来说具有极大的讽刺意味。但你对此有什么发现呢？
So there is more to the exercise, but I'm conscious of the time. But how have you found that? Did any of my values map onto yours or are there some missing for you? Why don't you jot down your thoughts and why don't you come on over to the Aspiring Psychologist community on Facebook. Join us there and let's discuss this episode and what it might have evoked for you. During the Declan Sci application season, the membership is open with no need to wait on the waiting list. So if you do want to join us please do so and it'd be a pleasure to have you there we have got um our mindfulness course which is running
所以这个练习还有更多内容，但我很在意时间。不过你觉得怎么样？我的价值观有哪一个与你的相吻合吗？或者对你来说有什么遗漏的吗？为什么不把你的想法随手记下来，然后来 Facebook 的“有志心理学家社区”（Aspiring Psychologist Community）找我们呢？加入我们，一起来讨论这期播客以及它可能引发你的共鸣。在申请戴克林·赛伊（Declan Sci）的季节里，会员社群是开放的，无需在候补名单上等待。所以如果你确实想加入我们，请务必加入，有你的加入将是我们的荣幸。我们有我们的正念课程，将在
in um september october and november it's an eight week program and if you dive in now you can absolutely come and watch the first one on replay. Then you can come along to all other seven sessions live. And it's just going to be so wonderful. People in the membership are really looking forward to it. And we can help make this your most compassionate, mindful application season yet. Please do like and subscribe both on the YouTube channel and on your favorite podcast outlet of choice. I am going to get myself a nice cup of tea. I don't often allow myself to drink green tea with lemon anymore.
9月、10月和11月进行，这是一个为期八周的项目。如果你现在加入，你绝对可以来看第一节课的回放。然后你可以来参加其余所有七场直播。这将会是如此美妙。会员社群里的人们都非常期待。我们可以帮助这成为你迄今为止最具同情心、最具正念的申请季。请务必在 YouTube 频道和您喜爱的播客平台上点赞并订阅。我要去给自己泡一杯好喝的茶了。我以前经常不让自己喝带柠檬的绿茶。
Clipper is my favorite because caffeine doesn't always love me. But I'm feeling that after a day of sadness and reflection, that what I'm going to do next is before going to get the children, I'm going to make myself a nice. So, you know, sometimes we can take small moments of self-care. Self-care is not always face packs and manicures. Just rather than squeeze an extra, you know, 30, 40 minutes into my day, like I've done with doing this podcast, just to allow ourselves just a little bit of decompression time to tell ourselves that we really are very special we're doing a good job we deserve to be looked after so how might there be some flex in your day to look after yourself hope as ever this has been useful for you you'll be very pleased to know that with the birth of the new book, The Aspiring Psychologist Collective,
克里珀（Clipper）是我的最爱，因为咖啡因并不总是那么爱我。但我感觉到，经过充满悲伤和反思的一天之后，我接下来要做的是，在去接孩子之前，我要给自己泡一杯好茶。所以，你知道的，有时我们可以享受自我照顾的小时刻。自我照顾并不总是敷面膜和做美甲。与其在我的日程里挤出额外的30、40分钟（就像我录制这期播客时做的那样），不如允许自己有一点点减压的时间，告诉自己我们真的很特别，我们做得很好，我们值得被照顾。所以，你的日常生活中可以腾出怎样的弹性空间来照顾自己呢？一如既往，希望这期节目对你有所帮助。你会很高兴地知道，随着新书《临床心理学家集锦》的诞生，
that there might well be another jingle in the pipeline, which is always very exciting. I haven't even heard it yet. So, yeah, very much looking forward to sharing that with you too. But until then, look forward to this one. Enjoy this one, and I'll see you very soon. You can catch our next episode from 6am on Monday thank you so much for being part of my world this is episode 42 and if
筹备中的另一首铃声可能也已经在路上了，这总是令人非常兴奋。我甚至都还没听过呢。所以，是的，非常期待与你们分享它。但在此之前，期待这一期吧。享受这一期，我们很快就会再见。你可以在周一早上6点收听我们的下一期节目。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。这是第42期节目，如果你一路相伴至此，
you've been here all throughout thank you so much it means the absolute world take care guys bye if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist
非常感谢，这对我意味着整个世界。保重，朋友们，再见。如果你正期待成为一名心理学家，那么就让这期节目作为你的指南。有了这个播客一路相伴，你将稳步迈向获得专业资格的道路。这就是由玛丽安博士主持的《有志心理学家》……我叫贾娜（Jana），是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集锦》这本书。我发现里面所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历真的非常有趣。
it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
通往这个职业的路径竟然有这么多，这让我感到惊叹，而且成为心理学家并没有什么完美单一的方式。这让我充满了信心：不，我没有做错，这减轻了我对自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书来让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，你就不会把它放下。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。